Mike Tirico was there in Boston last
night as the Blues beat the Bruins and
he joins us now what was that atmosphere
like in Boston last night Mike
it was stunned I really thought they
just assumed that and how could you
blame them because every time a Boston
TV shows up in a championship they win
winning Game six on the road seeing Luis
without game 7 experience comes to
Boston they all thought the fans in the
area that Boston was just going to win
and it would be a party until 1:00 or
2:00 a.m. st. Louis I think learned a
lot from the game six they played and
brought what they were missing to Game
seven and we're physical and control the
game and good for them and good for the
city too but also I'm curious and so
with the dance when you're there pregame
and Doc emmerich throws it to you can
you hear anything you know like your
yeah producer is giving you a cue I mean
it was so loud there well it's not
feeling like it's been in st. Louis
there's a couple of games before it is
really loud you know that's the best
thing actually the best career purchase
that I've made here the same earpieces
that the rock the rock and roll guys
we're up on stage but you put those
double ears in and you can not hear
anything but what's going out over the
air which is great now you look really
cool like you'll see Jagger or you'll
see a musical hey I have those you know
I have this you can't seem like that or
play like that but but that's what I
love the hockey and you've noticed
you've known it when you've done this or
been to games the electricity in a
building is just a little different this
looks just a little bit of a different
edge because the physicality and the
speed of the game and the passion of
hockey fans it it was fun to be in the
build I have never seen the cup skated
and afterwards I was done with my
responsibilities I went out watch the
Blues for 15 minutes this is a fan it's
just really fun to see that happen and
also it's one of the great traditions
it's one of the more awkward ones but
it's it's a great tradition in sports
where the Bruins all right there just
waiting they got to wait for the Blues
to go down the line there shake it hands
good game good game good game and I
couldn't help but focus on Brad Marchand
and just going oh my gosh the internet
was having a field day
with him because the camera was staying
on him and he was he had tears in his
eyes and he's an all-time pest you know
the guys that you love when they're on
your team you hate when they're on the
other team and if you're on the other
team you love seeing a guy like that be
miserable but he's pretty cool he went
from the total pest to a hundred point
guy this year in the league and it was
you know again it's been good for hockey
the last couple years they buy this
Vegas no fan base gets to the final
Washington finally gets a cup st. Louis
wins a cup those are generations of fans
in three markets that will be into
hockey here going forward so I think it
was actually a pretty pretty good last
couple of years to the sport even with
the Rangers Chicago Philadelphia the
Kings the Blackhawks not making the
playoffs somehow it still ended up being
a pretty positive year and you look at
this team in January interim head coach
you got a fourth or fifth string
goaltender that you brought up from the
AHL like you
you can't script this stuff not not for
a second and and that is the cool thing
because I don't you know we did a lot of
nights of Sports Center where you know
okay 16 teams gonna make the playoffs
out of 21 or then 23 of the NHL how
meaningful is the regular season
well now look at these guys in January
they were dead last and they're in April
they made the playoffs so getting in the
tournament is not easy and now getting
in the tournament means you've got a
chance to advance here so to go from
worse team just after New Year's to
champion difficult Father's Day is
pretty sick and gives everybody and all
these cities hope you get off to a poor
start or your season he's Mike Tirico
from NBC Sports joining us from Boston I
was watching the golf channel last night
and they were recapping 2000 with Tiger
US Open at Pebble Beach still the most
impressive
I think weekend or week of golf that
we've had in the history of golf and he
probably had the second most historical
week and that was an Augusta when he won
by 12 but you were on the call the first
two rounds with Tiger what do you
remember about that yeah Thursday Friday
was on ESPN at that point I was I was
doing the ABC golf we were able to work
with the NBC guys on the cable coverage
at what what I remember honestly was
we had these really long fog delays you
know the marine layer rolls in and Tiger
was in such cruise control and
commanding everything and he kept
thinking well is his momentum gonna be
stopped because of the fog delay is he
gonna know not find what he had the
first stretch here what he was backed
out and he just got even better and
better but he had such control of all of
his clubs because as you know you go out
there for the show every February those
greens are the smallest greens they play
so if you're not locked in you've got
you're gonna have a problem and he was
as locked in perhaps as he's ever been
at Europe pebble do you think that's the
greatest tournament ever produced by a
golfer that he won a major by 15 shots
yeah you know for what we've seen you
know can I sit there and tell you you
know what what Saracen did back then or
Nelson did when he was running his 11
straight or anything like that I can't
but for what I've been around yes
without a question because was so
dominant it was so good and he was
playing the Golf Course like it was the
Pebble Beach pro-am in February where
you see guys get to double digits under
par except you looked at the rest of the
field and you know Ernie else is like 15
shots back and he's one of the best
golfers at that time so the difference
between Tiger and the rest of the field
there was probably as pronounced as it's
ever been
do you think that he created Brooks
koepka card on Father's Day weekend
dance
not literally mic night not literally
Wow in some ways yeah I mean look what
we've all fought the biggest Tiger
impact was going to be minorities coming
to the game more people who didn't look
like the rest of the guys who've been
playing golf for years playing golf
instead the bigger impact probably he
made golf cool so Dustin Johnson Brooks
koepka all these guys are 6-foot plus it
was shoulders that fit you know across
the room it was okay and cool to play
golf it to be like Tiger to be one of
those guys and this is now what you're
seeing you're seeing a generation of
guys who overpower the
and dad that's why I think this week's
would be interesting if you can't
overpower Pebble Beach you know the way
it's set up and in June there's there's
more traditional US open rough this is
going to look like the USO we grew up
with a little bit more so the bombing
gouge guys hit it 320 and wedge it out
we'll have a little tougher time playing
that game I think as this week plays out
great stuff there in the Stanley Cup
final mic safe travels and talk to you
soon
you too buddy happy Father's Day to you
and until the day that's all the day
that's to whom it applies that's Mike
Tirico joining us from Boston for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]